that in 1994 the book miss foot followed
Teach for America members during the
2005-2006 school year at Locke high
school in Los Angeles the event hosted
by the Los Angeles Public Library is 70
minutes good evening everyone I was
backstage and I didn't get to see the
hands go up of how many people here are
teachers and educators would you mind
doing it one more time just for Donna
and me Wow okay great and how many of
you have had a chance to read Donna's
book yet good okay
well that's so for those of you who
haven't it's a wonderful book and it's
kind of a rare opportunity to go inside
the classroom of some difficult schools
in this case a difficult school and to
see what it's like for classroom
teachers so my first question to you
Donna is what possessed you to write
this book and and what was the process
can you tell us how it happened well I
had been working at Newsweek and was
aware of Wendy Kopp from the very
beginning and was fascinated by this
idea that she had in her senior year at
Princeton to start a teacher core so I
kept clips and and thought hmm you know
I'd like to investigate this never
really got around to it didn't find a
good peg until the spring of 2005 when I
read a little news clip that said 12% of
the graduating class from Yale had
applied to Teach for America I thought
wow that's interesting at the same time
a very dear friend had just started
teaching at Locke high school and she
was telling me the problems that she was
having this was a mid-career switch for
her and she invited me to come and to
help and I got to her English classroom
and Eliza was doing Cat Cat ACT
Cat and these were ninth graders so
after 50 minutes it was clear to me that
they couldn't read the same day Liza
told me that Teach for America was
having their summer training institute
at Locke and I thought wow wouldn't that
be interesting to look at how we educate
our poorest and lowest performing
students through the eyes of our most
privileged students and so the book was
born well and were you shocked to read
in the paper a couple weeks ago of the
trouble not at all really I think as one
of the teachers in in the book Chad
Solio who's now at a greendot had
mentioned to me that the real news
behind the headlines was that these kids
can't read they're you know 11 percent
are proficient in in language arts and
two percent are proficient in algebra so
part of what happened in Locke I think
is is of course racial tensions which
are always there when you have two large
minority groups and part of it is what
happens when kids aren't educated and
they're not occupied and there's on
enough notes in charge I was at Crenshaw
last year and a bunch of kids were
milling around in the halls and I was
talking to the security guard about this
and expressing a little bit of concern
and he said simple Paul don't you
understand and the school for a lot of
these kids is not a place where they
come to get an education this is where
they do business which was a little
stunning comment and did you see
anything yourself that you're that that
showed you how difficult it is is to
teach what the teaching conditions are
like and there's an incident come to
mind that you could read to us tonight
from from observing
I think something like that yeah Paul
every day was difficult for every
teacher we have no idea what a difficult
job this is so I didn't certainly
because teachers are being asked to be
much more than instructors they are
referees they're coaches they are
psychologists it's it's an unbelievable
job but let me read you that the very
opening of the book which is the first
full day of September 2005 and it's it's
the very first page and this is Rachelle
Snyder who I don't think is here tonight
but this is what happened to her on the
day of a lockdown when the lights went
off in room 2 for one during her fourth
period special ed biology class
Rachelle didn't think anything of it the
bells seemed to ring constantly at Locke
high school why should she expect the
lights to work this Monday was the first
day of the first full week of the first
year of the first job of her
professional life never mind that she
had had only five weeks of training over
the summer Rachelle Snyder psychology
major and former captain of the
University of Pennsylvania soccer team
had become Miss Snyder or sometimes just
miss a special education teacher at
Locke high school in watts the
transition had been surprisingly easy to
make except for the 15 pounds she gained
teach for America's Institute aka boot
camp didn't bother her it was like
soccer training she woke up early worked
hard got the job done she was exhausted
they all were but during breaks when
other teachers and training were having
panic attacks
Michelle would catnap on the concrete
benches that line the walkway along
locks in her quad her long blonde hair
bunched up beneath her head like a
pillow trousers rolled up her pale skin
bathed in the harsh white light of the
LA Sun the day it started well she'd
gotten took a school early reviewed her
lesson plan and made sure that the desks
were still arranged in clusters of four
exactly the way she'd left them on
Friday the morning had flown by the kids
in the early periods were attentive
eager to please she particularly liked
her girl heavy third period three 14
year olds had children of their own at
home and a fourth was pregnant
she found that out after she had the
kids make peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches as a way to introduce the
idea of steps and procedures and science
you think I don't know how to make
peanut butter sandwiches asked one girl
I got a baby at home and he always be
screaming for them maybe it was
Michelle's blonde hair and light blue
eyes the girls seemed drawn to her
sudden even brought their friends to the
classroom to get a look-see they
squealed she looks just like a Barbie
doll Michelle couldn't access their
computerized individual education
programs ie PS the government mandated
plans of instruction and services
especially tailored to meet the specific
needs of each student with a diagnosed
learning disability so she had no way of
knowing how these smart streetwise kids
girls have come to be sitting there
hanging on her every word she had a
pretty good idea how the twenty boys in
her fourth period class got there they
were in special ed because their
behavior interfered with their ability
to learn it was certainly interfering
with her ability to teach these boys
were rude crude and disrespectful she
didn't think it had anything to do with
her gender her race or her youth she was
reasonably certain that they behaved
badly with every authority figure it was
only five days into the school year and
she felt she was already losing control
of period four she had been wrestling
with how to handle all her special ed
kids but these boys were especially
troubling her instinct was to try to win
them over with kindness they probably
had enough stuff single women in their
lives she wanted to show them something
else do I continue to be nice if I do
will they break me as the boys straddled
in shorts hanging low on their hips
t-shirts on inside-out some with do acts
hugging their heads
she felt tense she worried about two of
her African American students cousins
Martell and DeAngelo who'd almost gotten
jumped on their way to school the Friday
before the boys had come into class that
day subdued scared to leave the building
unless she walked them out what will
they be like today then there was Raul
last week she'd handed out a survey
asking generic questions about the kids
goals and attitudes toward school
Raul's response stopped her cold he said
he hated teachers and liked to kill he
drew a picture of a building with a boy
on top firing a rifle the bubble said
die [ __ ] there were stick figures on
the ground running away from the words
kill kill kill
Rochelle grab the seating chart and was
surprised to find that the artist was a
quiet little Latino kid one of the few
boys in class who didn't cause trouble
he kept his head down and his eyes
averted she didn't think he was looking
for attention was with his threatening
handiwork she thought he was an
emotionally disturbed boy who needed
help she alerted the principal dr. Frank
Wells immediately he seemed on top of
things my role was one of some 3100 kids
in his charge will Raul be in class
today will he have killing on his mind
five ten minutes have passed before
everyone was seated the day's lesson was
about the scientific method the kids
were going to test the manufacturers
claim that the fertilizer miracle-gro
was conduct guaranteed to produce
especially Hardy plants each group of
four was given seeds a pot of soil and a
bucket of water only half the class had
shown up but Rochelle was actually
relieved the fewer there were the more
easily she could maintain control after
explaining the project she'd moved from
group to group
praising those busy at work gently
scolding those who were falling around
the room hummed with a sound of the kids
voices as they prepared their pots
Michele began to relax then the lights
went off at first it didn't seem like
cause for alarm but within minutes
Rochelle could hear the sound of kids
running up and down the stairwell and
along the hallway outside her room her
students heard the commotion too
suddenly the vibe in the classroom
changed the kids were uneasy distracted
the air felt charged the room dangerous
Rochelle peeked out the door students
were literally running wild shouting and
jumping one another in the darkness
graffiti artists had whipped out their
markers and were signing the walls with
gleeful abandon the security guard who
usually sat within 10 feet of Rachelle's
room was missing she slammed the door
shut you are not leaving she said to her
students her voice rising and fear sit
down let's get back to work but the kids
were unsettled somewhere at the door
clamoring to get out
others circled the desks itching for
trouble when told to sit they refused in
order to continue working
they said the experiment sucked Rochelle
tried to keep teaching as she bent over
to inspect one kid's pot her t-shirt
inched up her back revealing a passion
bear white flash above her hip-huggers
Dante a tall skinny black boy made a
farting noise the classroom erupted and
laughter encouraged he announced in a
high-pitched voice that he had to pee
Rachelle told him he was forbidden to
leave the classroom Dante insisted that
if he was not allowed to leave he would
pee in the classroom as he began to
lower his pass the kids taunted him it's
so small your dick is so small they
dared him to make good on his threat she
wants you she wants to see you do it do
it you want to do it they chanted he did
it
Dante urinated in a water bucket right
in the middle of Miss Snyder's class a
shell order the entire class out of the
room you guys need to leave now
Dante you need to stay I want to
transfer out of this class said one boy
as he left the room it sucks what about
me pleaded Dante can I get out of here
wow I wonder if the graduating class
from Yale if they read that that 12
percent of them are going to sign up for
a Teach for America after reading that
particular incident
speaking of about Teach for America is
it possible for a fresh out of college
with with a short period of preparation
for this army of teachers to go out
there and actually have a positive
impact and in really tough schools and
help address the achievement gap do you
believe well the Teach for America has a
two pronged theory of change I don't
think it's possible and I would imagine
that Teach for America would agree that
it's possible to close the achievement
gap by sending a small Corps 5,000 or so
relatively inexperienced teachers into
classrooms where the needs are the
greatest
however Teach for America does have a
two-pronged theory of change and the
idea is that in the short term there
will be cattle at a catalytic change in
that by choosing very carefully their
candidates who they send into the
classrooms they will they will send the
best and the brightest who will with
their brains and energy have a dramatic
impact on student achievement over the
two two years that they are in the
classroom but the second prong of the
theory of change is that these Teach for
America teachers will be so transformed
by their experience that they will
whatever they do once they leave a
classroom be agents of change and
whether they be lawyers or doctors or
politicians or reporters they will be
the people who will force the change and
we're beginning to see some of that if
you look around the landscape of
education reform you'll see lots of TFA
alums and the Washington Post calls that
the TFA insurgency in fact last year
Michelle Rhee was named DC Chancellor's
of schools and she's a Teach for America
alum and another good example is the
Kipp schools
knowledge is power program which is a
string of charter schools which I'm sure
you're familiar with started by TFA
alums and are having tremendous success
are there any TFA alums here who are now
doing things other than teaching or
planning for careers in education where
you're moving out of the classroom I
know at least a couple are yeah well
we're talking about reforming public
education after your your year at Locke
what do you think it's gonna take to
make it possible for teachers to teach
and conditions like the conditions that
you described at this school because the
lock is not an aberration there there
are schools like Locke all over the city
and all over the country so what's it
what's it gonna take to make it possible
for teachers to teach and consequently
students to learn that's a big question
I know I knew the answer let's kick that
one around let's kick that one around a
little bit well first of all I think
that the American public has to you know
look at this problem and
and demand change okay so number one we
have to make education a priority in
this country because it's not just the
children in at lock or in inner-city
schools or poor rural areas that are
at-risk 1.2 3 million kids dropped out
of high school this year
70% of our our children graduate within
four years that's that's not good and in
terms of our ranking in among the
industrialized nations we're 19 so we
are 25 years after a nation at risk a
nation at risk so so that would be my
first point I think we have to really
tackle this problem which is why the the
what you said about the importance of
TFA the second point that you made is
that these TFA graduates are alums once
they've taught their two years in tough
schools when they when they go out into
the world they're going to be telling
the world a story that the world so far
the United States doesn't particularly
want to hear and that is that there and
this is a plug now from for my latest
book that there really are not only two
Americas but there's two education that
are taking place in those two Americas
and my concern is that and that we've
been sold by a lot of people a bill of
goods that the problem is not funding
and that I mean I hear this all the time
that you don't solve problems by
throwing money at it you've all heard
that one or that the kinds of problems
we have can't be solved by money that
has to be better administration and so
on and so let me just give one example
of why I think that's that's false I've
been playing a game for the last five
years every time I talk to anybody in
LAUSD I ask him what the per pupil
expenditure is and I get a different
answer from everybody I've ever talked
to and every book that I read has a
different number but right now it seems
to be somewhere depending on who you
talk to between eight and ten
thousand dollars per pupil some people
say it's even eleven some people say
seven I've talked to principals at
saying 7 boy over I'd be thrilled if I
had seven and so God knows what the
number is but let's let's just split
that all those differences and call it
nine across town and the the private
school that I used to be the headmaster
of crossroads school they'll be spending
27 thousand dollars per pupil next year
and that's a big difference and you can
do a lot with 27 thousand dollars per
pupil that you can't do with nine
thousand so we were talking about how
many kids graduate and at one of the
local inner-city schools I asked the
principal I said well how many of your
kids go on to college and he said I
don't know and I said what do you mean
you don't know and he said well we don't
have a you know we don't have a college
counselor per se and the person who's
doing the college counseling you know
can't track these kids and we just don't
know and I said what's your best guess
and he said he also told me that they
have 1,800 kids in the ninth grade four
years before this a little less than
nine hundred of those kids in the 12th
grade
excuse me and I said well how many of
those nine hundred do you think go on to
college and he said well said and my
best guess is would be based on how many
of them come by the guidance office to
ask for college scholarship forms I said
well how many said usually a little less
than 300 and I said well and what's your
best guess of those 300 how many
actually fill them out mail a man get
accepted by college and enroll the
following September he said best guess
10% I said you mean 30 students he said
yeah so I said you're telling me that
out of your original 1898 errs your best
guess is the 30 of them are going on to
college I mean I was stunned and he said
yeah so what's it gonna change to take
that well for one thing it would be nice
to have enough money to hire a college
guidance counselor so that you could
encourage kids starting in the 9th 10th
11th and 12th grades to
College the kids at crossroads most of
them visit to college and they start
talking about which college they're
going to go to in the tenth grade it's
just sort of a given that they're gonna
go to college at the inner-city schools
that isn't the case and you can go right
down the list I mentioned Crenshaw
earlier I spent a year there trying to
help a little bit and they have they
have a beautiful dance studio but no
dance teacher and I can just one after
another things that you get at the one
school you don't get at the other and it
is a matter of money and the money is
there in our society it's just that our
priorities are all screwed up but I for
my money I would like to see teachers be
given the money I think Teach for
America has shown us one very important
lesson among many and that is if you
attach status and prestige to a job of
teaching you can attract the best and
the brightest to this profession and I
think what's happened is it's difficult
to be a teacher and live on a salary and
raise a family especially if you're you
know a single breadwinner family and you
know I think if we started paying our
teachers like we paid investment bankers
I think our problems would go away yeah
I agree
well when I'm asked by people what do
you think
there would take excuse me for having my
back to people over here but I'm trying
to look at you and ask questions when
people ask me what do you think it would
take to improve our public schools
I say well I there's three things I can
think of right away that I would do and
I'm focusing primarily on on inner-city
schools and and low-income schools and
that is I'd cut the class size in half
and so that the teachers can teach my
first year of teaching at a private
school I taught four sections of 12th
grade English and I had 12 and 13 kids
in each each section at a total of 48
kids to teach I could assign an essay
every week get it corrected handed back
those kids wrote about 30 essays that
year they also had about 15 paperback
novels and collections of poetry and
anthologies of plays to take to take
home
I could teach and it was a it was a joy
but give me five classes a day of 35 40
45 kids and tell me to teach English and
then say oh by the way we don't have any
books for you for them to take home
you're going to have to Xerox excerpts
from novels instead of having the kid
read the novel that's not teaching
that's I mean and and so what would I do
it cut the class size in half which
means you'd have to hire a hundred
percent more teachers in those schools
but we're having a hard time attracting
people to teaching so I bumped the
teacher the the the pay scale by
twenty-five fifty thousand dollars just
BAM first thing to do so where's that
money gonna come from well that that's
the the subject of my book it would come
from corporations paying their fair
share of taxes it would come from
progressive income taxes and would come
from estate taxes it would come from
from reducing our obscene defense budget
it would come from a lot a lot of places
the money is there on our society and
that would be that's just the start I
mean just to have have quality teachers
in classrooms where they can actually
teach that's just the start then you if
you were going to do it right you'd hire
even more teachers so that every kid in
lock and manual arts and and Crenshaw
and you name it would have the rich
curriculum that they would get in any
private school in this country that
they'd have choices in all the arts and
they'd have community service programs
and environmental ed trips you know one
of the things that that we desperately
need to do obviously is to take better
care of our environment well if you
graduate generations of kids who have
never slept under the stars never walked
through a forest never been been out on
the ocean how are they going to want to
save a planet that they've never had any
kind of a relationship with they've
never had any dress
experience and once you've walked
through a redwood forest you have a
whole different attitude towards the
cutting down of trees and and then the
destruction of the rainforest starts to
mean something to you
well how many inner-city kids get to
take these kinds of field trips that are
just sort of commonplace in private
schools it's just what happens in
private schools so I'm so it is money a
lot of it is money and we've got to
figure out you know some way of raising
the consciousness of the American public
that and that we're doing a terrible
disservice to our children I remember
reading a line that just knocked me out
by a British writer Marina Warner
someone was pointing this disparity of
not only wealth but the the quality of
education provided to young people in
America and she said well you know in
America you have expensive children and
you have cheap children and that's kind
of the way we're the way we're dealing
with it
well tell me a little bit more about
about your year and at that lock and and
one thing I'm kind of curious of do you
think that the green dots what are the
what are their prospects do you think
they're gonna come in and send eighty
percent of the graduates to college as
they're hoping to do and the various
stats that we read well I don't think
right off the bat but I I would bet you
that green dot would tell you there's
nowhere else to go but up and so I think
they're feeling that lock high school
has been flatlining for a very long time
and and if not flatlining declining so
it's time for a change and and I think
Green Dot thinks that their model small
safe local control parental involvement
will will be the ticket will we'll see I
mean those are they've set that bar very
very high 80% graduation rate is not
happening in LAUSD
for sure and in many suburban schools
even so let's see it's it's going to be
a daunting task but if they do it it
will hopefully become a blueprint for
how other big dysfunctional schools can
be turned around well I have this sort
of haunting fear that I won't say you
can't but that it's extraordinarily
difficult to change a school if you
don't change the neighborhood because
and I mean just the the very incident
that you read and what we read about in
the problems that teachers are dealing
with in inner-city schools schools don't
create drugs they don't create
homelessness they don't create
unemployment they don't create teenage
pregnancy they don't create gangs
schools don't create those things but
they have to deal with them on a day to
day basis and then you know the the the
the public I mean one of the reasons why
I hear people saying well you can't
solve these problems by throwing money
at them or they'll say well you can't
you're just throwing good money after
bad and but I'm not sure that you can
that you can dramatically change the
schools without without you know
changing the neighborhood well I think I
think it's right it's very difficult but
I I really don't believe that we're in a
position right now to fix the poverty or
fix the neighborhoods or the dysfunction
and that to me you know makes it all the
more important that we fix our schools
because this for many children is the
only place where there's ability and
where they can be safe and so I think
it's kind of a cop-out to say oh well we
can't educate these kids look they come
from dysfunctional families and poverty
and crime well no I think that's why we
have to do it
and and it is possible because there are
models out there we've seen it happen
you know the Kipp schools are doing it
and and some of the Green Dot schools
are doing it it can happen I hope what I
haven't seen yet and again this is
another issue I was at an amine
of a charter school management
organization today and one of the things
that that we really don't know yet is of
the the students that we get into
college how many and we're going to
actually graduate from college and of
course then here's another issue where
money comes into the picture because in
order to do a longitudinal study you
have to have the funds to do that and
again to give you the example of the
$27,000 per pupil versus the $9,000
Crossroads school and every other
private school in the United States and
every you know sort of elitist private
school and knows not only which college
their colleges their kids enroll in in
their freshman year they know which
colleges and the graduation rate and
they know where those kids are for the
rest of their lives partly out of
idealism and partly because they want to
you know because they want want them to
contribute to the school for the rest of
their lives but but they know where they
are why do they know where they are
because they have alumni offices who
track them for from the day they leave
high school until the day they die
literally and we don't know yet whether
we're preparing kids to pass tests so
that they can get into places where will
they be able to survive do they have the
critical skills to survive in some of
the colleges that we're getting these
kids into I hope so but we don't really
know and that's that's something that's
sort of one of the unanswered questions
and maybe when we when we have time for
Q&A maybe maybe some of the people here
will have observations on that but I
think that's one of the big unanswered
questions about charter school the whole
charter school movement every time I
think of a reform I have a hard time not
putting a price tag on that
so that well I do think though that the
most important crucial element in a
child's education is is human resources
I mean I really do think that it happens
the magic happens between the teacher
and the child it's a binary
relationship and that's where I would
want to see the focus is attracting and
training and selecting the highest
quality teachers and we've seen we have
a model from ta TFA actually well you
gave an example of a sort of a horror
story of the student you know of the
blackout and the student urinating in
the class I presume that you also saw
some exhilarating moments where teachers
had some breakthroughs with students do
a couple of those come one or two of
those come leaping to mind you know
they're they're little ones it's a lots
of times it's just the look on a kid's
face or the look on a teacher's face
when they see the light bulb go off but
I know at the end of Taylor's year
Taylor was a ninth grade English teacher
her kids were explicate Nkrumah and
Juliet no joke I mean they knew this
play and not you know not just facts
they understood it in the context of
their own lives
the Bloods versus the Crips it was very
powerful to watch that and and I saw
similar kind of moments
among all the teachers that that I
followed and I think that's what keeps
teachers teaching are those special
moments because it's not the salary and
it's not the working conditions right I
wonder if there are are there any TFA
people in the audience here that that
have a particular exhilarating story
that you might be willing to share with
us yourselves of a one of those great
great teaching moments
a hand yes great
a student that I had at the beginning of
the year was actually put back in jail
for the second time and he came out of
jail and went to meet with his probation
officer and told his probation officer I
want to go back to the school that I had
been in at the beginning of the year
and so we met with him and we told him
basically you're gonna have to repeat
seventh grade you've missed most of the
year and he said I want to do it I want
to do it the teachers here care about me
and you know what I want to be something
I want to make something of myself and I
was sitting there the end of the year
can be very tough very trying and was
totally inspired by this child who's had
just a extremely difficult year and was
mature enough and thoughtful enough to
make that decision and say I want to do
something with my life that's exciting
to hear any I mean I just want to jump
in here that the other thing that I
quickly saw when I was at walk is that
these children do want to learn you know
I always hear out there oh you can't
teach these kids in there you know
they're turned off and and you know
they're too hard or and yes some of them
have very hard exteriors but honestly
they do want to learn it's in our DNA
you know if you teach them they will
learn and they deserve it and you know
how could we sit here and let 30 out of
a thousand kids be eligible for college
you know how can we rob them of that
toehold on the ladder to success it's
it's mind-boggling to me
did you see examples in the classes that
you said and where I mean it I agree
with you I think in any given class the
majority of kids actually do want to
learn but one of the things that I see
happening is that there are a handful of
kids sometimes one or two in a given
classroom that make it almost impossible
for the teacher to teach yes no that
does happen for sure and you know of
course the teacher has to deal with that
and and probably the best solution is
for that child to leave that classroom
but for the majority of students and I'm
sure all the teachers in this room would
agree and that's why you teach it's so
magical it's it's it's so powerful and
these kids are so smart and so canny so
funny you know great kids the class
sizes that you observed a lot big big
in fact Philip had a class in which
there were not enough desks for his
geometry class and there was one kid who
would come and he'd stand at the front
of the classroom and he'd sort of wait
to find a desk knowing that there was no
way that there would be a full class
ever never would every kid in the class
show up so this kid was very quiet and
unassuming and he just you know cool
chill out until he found a seat and and
Philip felt very strongly that he did
not want to go to the administration and
say I need more desks because what he
needed were less desks less children in
the room and so he didn't want to send
the wrong message but in the meantime it
can't add no desk but we have 12 billion
dollars a month to spend and Iraq but we
can't have desks and books for our
students yes that's why I hand back
there here we got a mic coming for you
I'm a teacher at Locke high school and
we do have some students here today that
came to listen to your conversation
today I don't know if any of them were
in the in a TFA class but one of my
students do he does have a question for
you great yeah is that okay yeah I think
why don't we open it up for questions
now and so anybody and we're gonna for
the sake of the camera what kind of move
start from the left here and then move
over over to the right how you doing my
name is Trayvon Lewis thank you right
there I like it my question for you is
why are schools that you want to choose
Locke talked about
I didn't hear the question of say uh why
did why did you choose lock why I chose
lock because I knew lock and I also knew
that Teach for America was going to have
their Training Institute there so I had
visited the school and I and I had heard
from my friend a lot of things about
lock so it just seemed like a natural
place to go because this is where Teach
for America was training its teachers so
we're open for questions now yeah here's
another one hello everybody good evening
my name is Joseph Charlotte I'm also a
junior at Locke high school and I wanted
to ask Miss Foote what was the relevance
of putting the I will have to say the
stolen merchandise that mr. Zhu scooby's
received during the riots was the
relevance of put an ad in the book um
well did everybody hear the question
well there's a part in the book where
Zeus coupie is who is a revered teacher
at Locke high school recalls his time
during the Watts Riots when or no wasn't
the Watts rise I'm sorry it was the
Rodney King riots yeah well when it was
kind of a fire sale and people were
helping themselves to merchandise and
Zeus did not steal any any oh it was
well it was just describing I wanted to
describe what the area was like during
the Rodney King riots and and Zeus
remembered it very clearly and described
it for me and so I thought that would be
a paint a very good vivid picture of
what occurred in in the area around
Locke at that time questions over here
back there
yeah we'll get to you next maybe I was
just wondering how do you reconcile the
Teach for America model of selection and
attraction of high quality talent to the
classrooms with the unspoken elephant in
the room of the importance of teacher
retention and to maintain these high
quality well-trained teachers at
districts invest quite a lot of money in
who then leave most within two years and
many within five and I'm a TFA alum
who's no longer in the classroom so how
do you reconcile those two things that
seem to be irreconcilable well it is a
problem and it's not a pretension
teacher retention is not a problem
peculiar to Teach for America as most of
you know within five years 50% of
teachers are gone so it is true that
that Teach for America in in some
schools can can add to the problem of
teacher churning without doubt but again
I think nationwide of the 3.5 million
teachers 14 percent leave the first year
to you know so I don't think it's it is
a problem but it's not as I said it's
not Teach for America everybody has it
teachers are bailing and no one can
figure out a way to keep them and which
is why I think if we were able to attach
status and prestige to our teachers and
revere them and and yeah I think we'd
read CSE change I think maybe some
people saw I think it was about six
months ago and in the New York Times a
charter school in New York were where
they're paying the teachers 125 thousand
dollars I mean that and that was that's
kind of the goal every teacher not just
not just the ones who've been there for
20 years or whatever in fact there
couldn't be because it was a brand new
school so everybody who's gonna get 125
thousand dollars and there's a there was
a book I'm blanking on the author's name
recently the hundred thousand dollar
teacher you have to the way the system
is now you you have to teach you know
for your lifetime to get up
up to that to that number so you're
right I mean if we paid teachers maybe
they'd stand but I think we have to also
ask ourselves if if Wendy Kopp hadn't
founded TFA and if TFA didn't exist you
know that would that that would be a
real loss in this country and it's it's
funded with primarily with private
dollars so I mean it's a it's an
extraordinary contribution to the
educational landscape that was a
question over here and then right down
in front here next right over there to
your left yeah Russian though is in most
private schools teachers actually have a
lower salary than in public schools how
does that fit in with your description
of $100,000 I'm actually the the the
private schools that I know have done a
done a pretty good job in the last 5-10
years and raising the the salary scale
one that I know quite well starts at 52
now and there are teachers in the 80s
and 90s but private schools have tended
to lag behind public schools play
catch-up and then fall behind as as
public school salaries go up and then
catch up but the difference there is
that the teaching conditions are so
extraordinary that you would never leave
that for a few thousand dollars to go
and have five classes a day of forty
five kids when you could have four
classes a day of 15 systemic things
rather than individual teachers because
I think even very good teachers cannot
stay as teachers because of a lot of
things besides the money right I agree I
mean just feeling being safe would be
nice too I mean there's there's a
question right down here in the front
very front row oh here we go what I find
a friend of mine is a teacher and she's
a retired teacher so she wants to do
substitute teaching and she told me the
other day she came into this class
and the first thing this boy walked up
during the sister
you're an old hag and what are you doing
in here
they really insulted her I mean that's
that was her hmm
hello for the day how can you keep
teachers well if you have that know a
respect that's I know when I went to
school we revered our teachers right now
I agree that's and she wasn't the only
one the other night I went to another
event and I was just talking to a lady I
didn't even know and she told me she was
a teacher and that a student was very
insulting to her too
so how do you keep these people you know
well I mean I think that goes goes back
to the the whole notion that that the
problems were dealing with here are not
just the school's problems they're their
neighborhood problems they're community
problems and if the if the teaching
conditions were dramatically different
the kind of incident that you described
wouldn't be possible that kid would be
and that kid would be out of the
classroom very quickly and would be in
in some kind of a program where he would
be taught some manners and so on but
yeah yeah
um mr. foot my question for you is per
memo from Rochelle Snyder she sent out a
memo to all the loc high school staff
divorcing herself from the book because
she was very surprised at the content of
the book and apparently out of the
teachers that you observe she's the only
one left there at Locke high school how
do you feel about that well that's that
hasn't been communicated to me by
Rochelle I'm surprised to hear that I
don't know I
you'd have to talk to her she'll about
that okay
I'm not sure I sort of would like to
hear a little more about what that is
about I'll just say that I volunteer a
net loss this year with the college
counselor who unfortunately is not going
to be there next year closely with the
seniors and got a very good result from
about a hundred and twenty-five kids are
going to be waiting into school to
college eight got into UCLA it got into
Berkeley a handful got into Santa
Barbara Merced and I think what's
unfortunate is that LAUSD is not going
to give them green dot the money they
had promised to have a college counselor
for next year but there's a great spirit
there and you know it seems like it's
got a lot of students who really want to
learn like you said oh I love Locke High
School and I and I you know I love the
students and and the teachers that I met
were unbelievable there's lots of very
good teachers at Locke high school
there's just not enough of them and
there's lots of great students too and
lion tremendous potential that has yet
to be tacked to questions down front
I have questions about LAUSD what would
you do with LAUSD to try to fix it and
my next question is did your presence in
the classroom and at the school
generally change the vibe in any way did
your presence sort of create some of
what occurred well I don't think so
I think after a while I was kind of like
wallpaper but Haraka malian is here in
nuraghe is one of the teachers that I
followed and maybe Harrah could tell you
if he feels I was a you know students
behave differently because of me but it
wasn't my sense I think they you know
sort of after a while just forgot I was
there I'm sorry I should have introduced
her AAG we had many visitors coming in
another classroom so the students were
used to people coming in and out and
Donna was like she said just the wall on
the fly fly on the wall hog Rock taught
biology and is now hoping to open his
charter school next September and next
our AAG I'd like to introduce Chad so
Leo who was the assistant principal at
Locke and is now the principal at an
animal at Brown and having very good
results with his students Oh LAUSD oh my
goodness I I don't know what to say
there I think it's too big it's
dysfunctional I I think Paul would be a
better person to address that you've
been in the trenches much longer well I
think LAUSD is making making an effort
to respond they're trying to create some
more innovative projects it's it's it's
a huge district with with huge problems
I sure wouldn't want superintendent
Brewers job
I might I don't know I don't know what I
would do given that given the
limitations that that office has I would
I would want to do the things that I've
been talking about it I want to try and
and improve the teaching conditions for
teachers I don't know how I'd do that in
a climate where now you're looking at
budget cuts which is you know here we
have what is California the sixth or
seventh biggest economy in the world and
we're talking about budget cuts for our
public schools to me it's just it's just
insane and all I hear is it's as though
people have forgotten that that an
economic balance sheet has two sides to
the ledger we just keep looking at them
at the expense side and talk about what
we can cut and one of these days we're
going to have to wake up and and and
look at revenue I mean I imagine I can
sort of imagine myself going in front of
the parent body at my old school
crossroads and saying parents and I've
got a some great ideas for improving our
school we're going to expand the
curriculum we're going to create better
conditions for teachers and we're going
to do this by cutting tuition and that's
sort of the logic that we're applying to
our public schools now so as long as
we're in that kind of a climate I'm not
I'm not sure what a large district like
LAUSD can do with the kind of funding
restrictions that they have there was
another question here I had a couple of
points of clarification I think might
help I also teach it Locke high school
and I read the memo from Rochelle Snyder
that went out to all of the teachers as
I interpreted that she did not divorce
herself from the book she was very
sensitive to some of the comments in the
book she wanted to make sure that she
didn't wasn't seem to be criticizing
people who were there at the school now
for some of the things that she might
have said but I didn't see her exactly
dissociating herself in the book least
as I interpreted it also about the
college counselor back here I was at a
meet-and-greet on last Friday for the
first time a new green dot teacher
were collected and I sat next to a young
woman who was a TFA alumni I was her
faculty advisor and she's telling me
she's going to be the college counselor
at Locke high school next year under
green dot so I also had a question that
I wanted to ask Paul my old headmaster
no no Paul you are familiar with I
assume you've read the book and you're
familiar with the Teach for America
management philosophy in terms of a lot
of data analysis and so forth when
you're reading through that what did you
think about that well and what more
respect for example how people within
the organization get promoted how
teachers are assessed on the basis of
data and so on I I don't know that I can
really comment on that I don't know that
I don't know how TFA operates well
enough to make an intelligent
observation there I'd mire the
organization tremendously yeah and I
just look at the number of quality
teachers it's putting into tough schools
where if they didn't go there I don't
know who would I'm not trying to get you
to like criticize Teach for America or
something it's just that the I know as a
man who spent a lot of his life with a
devotee you were a poetry teacher when I
was at Crossroads and and the
distinction between that and then the
the emphasis I read on measurable
results and so forth strikes me is very
interesting well it is it said it's a
national problem right now I think the
emphasis that we put on on on testing
and probably every teacher and and the
room here will will relate to the notion
that what testing is doing is squeezing
the joy out of education and I think you
know it it's probably the second biggest
cause of driving teachers out out of the
field second only maybe to pay and and
and and and maybe its first along with
it's it's part of the teaching
conditions that I think demoralize
teachers because they can't they can't
teach the thing
that passionately drove brought them
into teaching in the first place and to
have scripted textbooks that to read
from it certain grade levels is just
anyway yeah once again I'm Joseph
Sherlock Alec I jr. and before I ask my
question
I will went to vite miss Donna foot
because I am the president of the mole
acronym for men of life delegation which
we hold our group I mean we hold our
meetings every Monday at lunch the kind
of shape our young black males and
latino males in the community to be
outstanding citizen you know to just
learn how to be a man our slogan is boys
will be boys but men must be men and I'm
also the vice president of the black
student you ain't the BSU and I would
love for you to come to our school and
have a Q&A session I feel kind of my
school is kind of misrepresented in the
book and we only have mr. Smith one of
our teachers and just this group of
students and you kind of elaborate it on
some students that I know in school and
they've kind of felt the same way but my
question is I have an excerpt from the
Los Angeles Times called rewriting the
history of Locke high school
it's called rewriting the Locke high
school story and I'm gonna read this
excerpt to you because I'm going to
clarify something I want something
clarify the plan I'm sorry all right
here it is when only three percent of
black students are receiving the
education required to get a toehold on
the American Dream should we be
surprised at a melee on the quad after
all as educational reformers would
observe if only 3 percent of the garbage
in LA were being picked up that would be
rioting in the streets so can you kind
of clarify your metaphor to lock high
students riding and the garbage on the
street well I didn't I didn't I just
meant that that education and of our
young people at law high school is so
important that a three percent rate of
kids being eligible for college is is
absolutely unacceptable and if something
as
trivial as garbage on the street were
being picked up at that same rate the
mayor would be run out of town and
they'd be rioting in the streets I was
making that point I was making that
comparison to show how terrible this is
you know it's interesting that you
mentioned 3% because I just read a study
recently done at the University of
Chicago where they took the top hundred
and sixty-four colleges in America and
then they took the four quartiles of
America economically and they looked to
see where the enrollment of those top
hundred and sixty four colleges comes
from and as you might guess well mate I
mean it was surprising to me to some
degree seventy-five percent of the
enrollment of those hundred and
sixty-four colleges came from the top 25
percent 22 percent came from the next
two quartiles
in other words ninety-seven percent of
the enrollment of those 164 quote top
colleges came from the top three
quartiles which means the three percent
came from the bottom quartile and my
guess is that of that three percent
probably 50% of them were athletes so
you know we've gotten as a society a
long way to go before we can look to our
low-income neighborhoods and
neighborhood schools with a sense of
pride in a sense that we're doing that
we're fulfilling our responsibilities as
a society because we're not now so yeah
let's move over
maybe front row here do you want to just
shout it out and I'll back here okay
great next year yes I'd like to know
once Teach for America goes to a school
do they continue to go there every two
years with a new group do is someone
going to be at lock from Teach for
America it depends it you know the
teacher for America teachers are hired
like any other teacher so you know it
depends on
if there are openings and if the
principal feels that the particular
candidate is a good fit so for the past
several years yes there's been Teach for
America teachers there every year but it
really is up to each individual
principal to hire there's a question
down front here that racial tensions
between these two dominant these two
groups that you're talking about Latinos
and african-americans and Locke and
other schools similar schools are they
getting worse or staying about the same
and how did teachers deal with that and
how does that affect their ability to
teach to be honest when I was at Locke I
didn't feel the racial tensions I mean
you knew that you know there were they
existed but I I think the campus was
very safe and and well maintained and
kids students sit next to each other in
class and joke and you know they're on
the at lunch periods they would
segregate by interests or you know but I
didn't feel the tensions that that much
I think this year has been difficult for
the students at Locke because there have
been a wider area of enrollment so that
there have been different rival gangs
introduced into what was once a Crips
only school and there's been less
supervision and and there's been a sense
I think from many from what I can tell
from some of the teachers and students
of abandonment because LAUSD is leaving
lock and greendot is coming in and I
think this transition year has been
difficult for all a lot of uncertainty
there's four hands that are frantically
waving in the back back here
I think these folks went our way in
hello my name is Reggie Andrews I'm
actually the senior staff member at LOX
there's no one been there longer than me
and it's actually my neighborhood where
I can walk to my mom's house and so
their book kind of took me back Locke
has always been a media event
one thing that LAUSD has done is prepare
our kids for failure social promotions
goes on you can you can fail for classes
in the fifth grade you still go to sixth
grade you'll fail to class in the sixth
grade you'll still go to seventh grade
you can fail seventh grade English and
math and you'll still take eighth grade
in English and math then all of a sudden
Locke's gotta fix it that is a number
one problem at Locke high school it's
not addressing that reality so they've
been you might say socialized for
failure so they may find out two years
down the line that oh I'm not gonna move
up to the next grade one interesting
thing is that Green Dot is introducing
for Locke next year is they're actually
bringing the same concept in because now
the ninth graders who may fail two or
three classes will be designated as 10th
graders starting September even if they
failed classes but that I guess that
might be a good thing
teaching there's a calling I I embrace
and and and like the fact that teach
America teachers are coming to Locke
because there's a big hole for teachers
people who are concerned they're little
I don't think they're ready for the
culture that they're gonna walk into and
it was just interesting reading your
book with a lot of those facts seem to
be missing and I think I could have
written the same book about Beverly
Hills High School and some of those
stories but Locke has always been a
media event and I would love for you to
come to the school and it's interesting
that you wrote a chapter called them in
a block an organization that I created
and you never talked to me I just find
that to be interesting well
oh I just want to kind of go more into
the so-called racial tensions at my
school it's all just false propaganda
it's all I mean the day after the riot
the very next day I was playing
basketball with Latino students I mean
we got along together so fine like
nothing happened I mean every since then
you you if you if you were walk the
campus right now tomorrow at school you
would assume the same thing that nothing
really happened and when it comes to
these like I mean it's all the gang
thing you may have one gang Latinos and
one gang of blacks and if you see them
go at it and you see a big crowd around
them of course you're going to kind of
assume it's racial tensions but it all
comes down to a gang thing if you're on
the outside looking in that's kind of
what you assume of it oh yeah well these
blacks don't like these grounds but it's
all the gang thing and um that's kind of
false what you said about our school
being predominantly [ __ ] because it's
not the biggest school I mean the
biggest black gang at my school are the
Bounty Hunter watch out the Nickerson
garden which are floods and the biggest
latino gang from my school or South
flows and for what I see because I've
been on both sides of fence walking
through the handball courts the
basketball court found a bear hole which
majority of the gangbangers hang out at
there are no such tensions or no racial
tensions no anything when it comes down
to a fight between a black and brown
Latino it is mostly a game oriented
theme or is tagging anything related to
games our turf is not have nothing to do
with race because some of my best
friends and I put emphasis on that some
of my best friends or Latinos and we
love each other oh and also it was a 600
I was there throughout the duration of
the riot the melee I consider more of a
melee than a race right because it
wasn't a riot it was like kind of a
freefall like my problems with this
gentleman here and I couldn't I couldn't
be aggressive with him on school campus
so it's a big fight with like 50
students over there I got my opportunity
there's a freefall it was a male
in it one 600 it was probably about a
little less than 100 students fighting
and no just yeah it's like big crowd big
versus of crowd just going around just
fighting each other random so I just had
to kind of put that out there for y'all
thank you thank you one more question
the lady but now I'm you know this lady
here was been very patient
right it would seem obvious to me that
high school failure doesn't just happen
at ninth grade
the children were socialized for failure
they were passed on and on and on I
would like to hear comment how your
school was socializing the children and
what were the offering the offerings
that you gave them to make them into
successful high school students versus
what LAUSD is offering our students
because I have them in first or second
grade and they are not failures then
something happens in between Eddy that's
me okay
except for me are you referring to
private schools or to public schools
because I've been working with
well I think sure one of the things that
that happens I think is that somewhere
around middle middle school things start
breaking down when and when all of the
you know the turmoil of adolescence hits
and one of the things that that private
schools do again because of the teaching
conditions and the general culture of
the school they're able to keep the kids
engaged and so and there there isn't a
gang culture surrounding the school so
you don't have to deal with that there
are kids who are going going home
primarily to to two-parent families
families where both parents are college
graduates where their books in the home
where the neighborhood is safe I mean
that the conditions are just
dramatically different and and the
richness of the curriculum keeps kids
engaged so that you don't have eighteen
hundred ninth graders becoming seven or
eight hundred twelfth graders you at
Crossroads you have 125 ninth graders
125 seniors 125 going to college the
following 4 September and 125 graduating
from college four years later it's just
it's it's a different world and we have
to face up to that and start giving the
resources to inner-city schools that
kids just sort of automatically get in
in the more wealthy neighborhoods and we
need to say to ourselves as a culture
that that both neighborhoods are equally
important and so far we haven't been
willing to say that we've been willing
to to treat some neighborhoods as if
they were throw aways you know so I
guess that was the last question and I
think it's I think it's wonderful that
you all came out and Don us to be
congratulated for having given up a year
of her life to going into this school
and trying for trying to assess the
culture and I guess we'd been invited
back
and thank you all very much for coming
this evening
[Applause]
[Applause]
Donna foot is a freelance journalist and
former Newsweek correspondent relentless
pursuit